Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how NVIDIA’s crazy
new AI is able to understand basically any
human movement.
So, how is this even possible?
And even more importantly, what is pose estimation?
Well, simple, a video of people goes in, and
the posture they are taking comes out.
Now, you see here that previous techniques
can already do this quite well, what’s more,
if we allow an AI to read the wifi-signals
bouncing around in a room, it can perform
pose estimation, even through walls.
Kind of.
Now, you may be wondering what is pose estimation
good for?
By the end of this video, you will see that
this can help us move around in virtual worlds,
the metaverse, if you will.
But let’s not rush there yet, because still,
there are several key challenges here.
One, we need to be super accurate to even
put a dent into this problem.
Why?
Well, because if we have a video, and we are
off by just by a tiny bit from frame to frame,
this kind of flickering may happen.
That’s a challenge.
What else is challenging here?
Two, foot sliding.
Yes, you heard it right.
Yes, previous methods suffer from this phenomenon,
you can see it in action here.
And also, here too.
So, why does this happen?
It happens because the technique has no knowledge
of the physics of real human movements.
So, scientists at NVIDIA, the University of
Toronto and the Vector Institute fired up
a collaboration, and when I first heard about
their concept, I thought you are doing what?
But, check this out.
First, they perform a regular pose estimation.
Of course, this is no good, as it has the
dreaded temporal inconsistency, or in other
words, flickering.
And in other cases, often foot sliding too.
Now, hold on to your papers, because here
comes the magic!
Now, they transfer the motion to a video game
character, and embed that character in a physics
simulation.
In this virtual world, the motion can be corrected
to make sure they are physically correct.
Now, remember, foot sliding happens because
of the lack of knowledge in physics, so, perhaps
this idea is not that crazy after all!
Let’s have a look!
Now this will be quite a challenge.
Explosive sprinting motions.
And…whoa.
This is amazing.
This, dear Fellow Scholars, is superb pose
estimation and tracking.
How about this?
A good tennis serve includes lots of dynamic
motion, and just look at how beautifully it
reconstructs this move.
Apparently, physics works.
Now, the output also needn’t be stickmen,
we can retarget these to proper textured virtual
characters built from a triangle mesh.
And, that’s just one step away from us being
able to appear in a metaverse.
No head mounted displays are required, no
expensive studio, no motion capture equipment
is required.
So, what IS required?
Actually, nothing!
Just a raw input video of us.
That is insanity.
And all this produces physically correct motion.
So, that crazy idea about taking people and
transforming them into video game characters
is not so crazy after all.
So now, we are one step closer to be able
to work, and even have some coffee together
in a virtual world.
What a
time
to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!